i don't know where it's come from but
uh we've we seem to have decided around
the world to make a sixth joe carter
the sixth joe carter is just a small
section
from 12 to 18 of the 31 joe carter
it's a very good one for beginners
so if you know the 31 joe carter
then you can you can do this teach
beginners here
i can remember
once you've done the carters
you can then start to flow and move and
mix them
okay so you can sort of mix them up so
the six joe
carter as we call it is
13 14
[Music]
15 16 17.
18. but really 18 brings you back to
number 12. so but we start in
this position
once you if you want to then continue it
you
you keep in this position and then you
turn it into a carter
you know just flow flow flow
so
i just had a thought if what what i do
i don't know about other teachers but
what i do is i get somebody else to
mirror us
and we we cross over a line so there
where you are the camera
when i ski i step to one side and ski
to to them and they'll move to one side
and ski to me
i now cross the line and they cross the
line
and we strike they strike here so we're
mirroring each other
i now go back across the line
and they go across the line at this
point
we come together and the joes will clash
hash may not be the right word but you
know they come together
we'll then go back across the line
and then back across the line to ski
all right so we're starting now where
this where we started
because then we keep it going so we make
six movements
edge knee
sound
goal rock on the wrong side of the line
so we're going to now continue it
without being in the ready position so
we go
edge knee thumb
[Music]
then i'll make them do it in five
movements so we join the first two
edge
oh no sorry i made it three
so we go edge
and then
it brings me a little bit more straight
there doesn't it
itch
me
after you do that a few times i'll stop
the class and i go okay we're gonna make
four movements
h
[Music]
now the the thing is we take it down so
that it becomes
three movements one two
three edge
just do you know as many times you think
you can do it do it
then
[Music]
after you've done that a while bring it
down to one movement
okay so
i hope you enjoy this and uh please add
it to your repertoire if you don't know
it already
thank you for your time